this video centered around the dagang
and our mission to change the way the
world views black fatherhood was
captured prior to the horrific killing
of our brother George Floyd and the
ongoing protests against police
brutality and social injustice that
rightfully followed as his videos being
released trained yet another dark time
in our nation's history the dad gang is
sensitive to the anger and the pain that
this tragedy has caused and we will
remain as a beacon of light and source
of empowerment for young black farmers
across the nation
you got him okay
when I started the day again my mission
was to challenge the negative
stereotypes of black father than one
image at a time you don't go in the
dryer okay
[Music]
my name is Shawn Williams and I'm the
founder and president of the dad gang
incorporate the dad gang is a support
group for blacks fathers and we are the
mission to change the way the world use
black dads I do agree there's a
misconception about black parenting of
black fathers in America that a lot of
individuals believe that we aren't
involved in our children's lives but
that can be further from the truth
media influence plays a very big role in
how the world perceives us we change the
way that people see us as black fathers
by doing this with the curl Ready Steady
Go
okay think I'm playing with you yeah
[Music]
my mission was to challenge that
negative stereotype of one image at a
time so I began to record videos of me
and my kids and the things that we do
every day then I started to upload them
soon other dad started to notice and
they began to send their videos too from
there the dad gang started become
popular then we decided to take it one
step further and started doing events
around the country suddenly we had a
movement we had a ton of events lined up
for 2020 a lot of activities a lot of
dad meetups a lot of panels the pandemic
kid is hard and pretty much trying to
stop everything after the lockdown we've
been doing remote activities like the
dad game dance challenge first select
the danceable song something cool that
we could groove to then find an open
space third find an item we've decided
to use a ball for this one and we're
gonna play hot potato with it
lastly you and your kids make up the
best silliest craziest dances you can
and show us your dance moves
[Music]
I'm proud to say that the dad gang has
been more active than ever that sense of
community really needed to kick in now
he really did I loved his way the
ultimate goal of that dance challenge
was to lighten the mood of what we're
going through especially right now
there's a lot of love and patience that
goes into even teaching our kids a
coordinated dance
[Music]
you know having a child and becoming a
father is a major life change and you
all need friends building you know
like-minded individuals especially when
we're going through major life changes
I'm inspired and my friends are inspired
but I just will be sure of each other
and the love that will be put into
raising our kids every day it's a job
that we're incredibly proud of and this
is really the true essence of what it is
to be a young black active dad dad you
okay
you did great that's a wrap
[Music]